Moments ago, Vice
President Kamala
Harris arrived in Nashville,
where she is
meeting with state legislators and gun
reform advocates
amid the fallout from Tennessee
state Republicans decision to expel
two elected Democrats, Justin J.
Pearson and Justin Jones
from the legislature.
Jones
and Pierson broke House
decorum rules to participate
in gun reform
protests on the
legislative floor in response
to the deadly Nashville school shooting.
This is only the third time
that state lawmakers
have been expelled
from the Tennessee legislature
since the Civil War.
With us
now, Republican Tennessee state
lawmaker Brian Ritchie.
Representative Ritchie,
thanks for joining us, sir.
You were one of seven Republicans
who voted against expelling Democrat
Gloria Johnson
and one of just three Republicans
who voted against expelling
Representative Justin Pierson.
But you did vote to expel Representative
Justin Jones.
Can you explain your votes to us?
Yeah, absolutely.
So
I started sharing with leadership
and everybody
that I did not think
that expulsion was the right thing.
What these three individuals did was
completely horrible.
It was a disrespect
to our General Assembly.
Those members that have served before me
and that will serve in the future.
According to Article two, Section
12 of our Constitution.
Did it constitute them being expelled?
Absolutely.
In my opinion, was it warranted?
And I did not believe so.
Representative Jones, his office is right
next door to mine.
I had multiple conversations with him
this week.
Let him know that I wasn't in favor.
And essentially he told me that he wanted
to be kicked out
because his following was grow.
And he's
getting all this national exposure
and that the Metro City Council
had already
said that they were going to reappointing
back to the General Assembly.
So I was honoring his wishes
and voting for him,
but I didn't think that any of them
should end up getting kicked out,
even though it was warranted
based on the letter of the law.
So Republicans voted to expel
two young black men
and not the 60 year old white
woman, Representative Gloria Johnson,
who did the same thing.
Johnson says that that's because she's
white.
What do you think of that and
how do you think this looks
to the rest of the country?
And that's political nonsense.
If anything, it was too energetic,
youthful males
that were a little bit more animated
while they were up there. And MS.
Gloria Johnson, representing
Johnson, stood their seat
when the they played the video.
It clearly showed her
standing there, not doing as much.
And I think that swayed other members
to not vote for her.
And that's why she's still there.
Had nothing to do
with the color of their skin.
I respect all three of them
and their constituents
that voted for them.
I felt that they should stay.
I honored Representative Jones,
but I had nothing to do with race.
Anybody that statement
that was just trying to talk up
political nonsense,
that should not be discussed.
So I guess one of the other reasons
that this has
gotten so much
attention is just because
the punishment
seems so much harsher than the
than the offense.
And as you know, last year
the former state House
speaker, Republican
Representative Glenn Casado,
he was indicted
and arrested on federal bribery charges.
He's contesting that.
But he wasn't expelled for that in 2018
Republican state lawmaker
David Byrd
as we covered on our show at the time,
he was accused of sexually assaulting
three teenage
girls years
before when they were on his high school
basketball team.
He was not expelled.
If Republicans are so concerned
about decorum and conduct
why would burn and Byrd and Casada
be allowed
to keep their seats
as long as they wanted.
While these two gentlemen were ejected
and expelled,
I, I was not.
I'm a freshman lawmaker.
I just got elected.
I can't speak of what happened last year.
20. 18.
I know that the conversation
that was taking place
among the
Republican Party this week is
this is the first time
that this has happened
in any of our lifetime.
As far as for somebody just blatantly
coming out and
disrupting our floor session
and that a precedent had to be set.
And that's
what the Republican Party was sharing
as they were going around
and chatting among each other.
But not once did it end up coming up.
As far as
anything that happened in the past.
It was based on this right here.
And this had not happened
in any of our lifetime.
And we needed to set a precedent.
I didn't agree with it.
That's why I was against the expulsion.
But according to Article two, Section 12,
it's there in black and white
So, I mean, I guess
the issue
another reason that
this is getting such attention,
I think, is because of
the really offensive thing that happened,
which is that disturbed individual
going into the Covenant School
in Nashville and slaughtering
six innocent people,
including 39 year olds
at the Covenant School in Nashville.
Horrible offensive.
You know, just just a horrific
mass shooting and
it seems like
a lot of people outside the legislature
that lawmakers, Republican lawmakers
are more concerned
about a disruption on the floor
than they are about these
six innocent
people killed at this Christian school.
That that's complete nonsense.
That that's the narrative
that the media is wanted to share.
And that's what these three individuals
are want to share.
There's not one member of that body,
Republican or Democrat,
that was not devastated by this
horrific, horrendous
action that this lady took down there
in Nashville
when she went in there and murdered
these six innocent, sweet lives.
When it comes to the legislative process,
these same
three individuals that are up there
advocating and saying, I'm for gun
or we need in gun violence,
we need to protect
our kids were also
the same three individuals
that voted against such school
safety perceived bills yesterday.
And just in February,
there was a bill that
Chairman Faison introduced
that would allow more security in co-ops
with private schools and out of the seven
individuals that voted no,
three of them were up
for expulsion yesterday.
So it's
very hypocritical
when they want to get up there
and say we need to stop gun violence
and we need to protect our kids.
Yet they don't vote on legislation
that would actually end up doing that.
And when it comes
to the legislative process,
we have bill filing deadline
that was back in January
and they didn't submit
any bills
that would end up
moving through the process.
And then the state that bills
that are being voted on now
is just in reaction
to that horrible event
is nothing close to the truth
because those bills
were filed back in January.
They were planned and prepped
back in October, November and December.
So
that my heart goes out to the
families and the community.
And this is something
that should never end up happening,
but it's something that
every member up there
in the General
Assembly is working towards
and everybody
trying to make a political statement
that that's not what's happened.
It is so far from the truth. It's absurd.
I'm out of time,
but I just want to get a yes or no
on on this.
In the wake of the
the Parkland School shooting in 2018,
a lot of states passed red flag laws
that's been encouraged in the
in the national federal legislation
after the Valdez shooting.
But now your governor Bill
Lee Republican suggests
he might be open to a new red flag law.
Yes or no.
Is that something you'd
be willing to think about?
Can you repeat that last part?
Would you would you be
would you be willing to support
would you at least be willing
to consider a red flag law for Tennessee?
To keep guns
out of the hands of individuals
that have been flagged?
If Governor
if Governor
Lee brings it to the legislature
I'm not in favor of the term red flag.
Law is so broad
and it covers so many things.
I think that gun
law abiding
citizens should be able to keep guns.
There should be a process
which Tennessee already
has steps for somebody
to be declared
mentally not stable,
to be able to possess those guns.
That's already on the books.
But everybody wants to overlook that.
So I would have to look at whatever
particular legislation is.
But when it comes to a broad term
red flag law,
now, I'm not in support of that
because I don't know what that entails.
Tennessee state lawmaker
Bryan Richey,
thanks for answering your questions
today. Appreciate it, sir.